Hello everybody
My name is Markiplier
And welcome back to the World's...
Quietest
Let's Play
I thought to myself --
*inhale*
When I was meditating this morning
*mouth sounds*
What --
better way --
to test out the capabilities of this new room --
*rubs beard on microphone*
Than with another
WORLD'S
QUIETEST
LET'S PLAY
Floof the hair...
For pow-hair
*Scratching sounds*
So let's...
...get start-ed
*wet mouth sounds*
Oh look!
It's another big ball throw
Not as big...
And I like 'em big
You sack of crap
*inhales*
But the chances of you getting the correct...
spot...
are very slim
No!
You bag of tits
You son of a bitch
How dare you mash my face
If I have to do this bullshit, again...
I'll tear off your entire ass
and then feed it to yourself
Ahh...
The center square
The possibilities for victory...
...are endless
And you have just fucked yourself
Watch and weep
*nose breathing of frustration*
Victory is assured
There is no way that I can fuck this up
I am the greatest to ever exist
Come
along
Little Johnny
It has been...
... a while
I hope you don't mind
the...
bumpy ride that we're going upo-
Johnny?
Come back here you little shit
One s'more...
Unto the breach
Repelled
By who I thought was once my friend
Well
It seems I've found the secret to suck.
Come with Mommy
Little children
Little Johnny
Stay there
It's...
O- okay goodbye Susan
Susan made the right call
Huh...
Well...
I suppose this is better than actually trying
Now. Little Johnny
If you could ju-
I did not go --
That was not me
*inhale*
I take great offense to this
And I believe
You owe-
Well, nevermind
Thank you
If you could stop...
'Pooning
My butthole
What did I just say?
Oooh!
Five balls!
It seems my medical condition has worsened...
By a factor of two...
... Point five.
I don't like that
No
*quiet giggles*
My vengeance...
*inhales*
Will be endless
You will see horrors, un-
You sack of fuck
*Giggles*
I'm gonna catch it-
I caught it
*fails at trying not to laugh*
No...
*more giggling*
I'll catch it
*uncontrollable giggles*
Durr
I-it's me-ff
*giggles*
It's me
*mouth noises and giggles*
Duh- *Breaks into laughter*
Nnnduh- *More laughter*
I can't do the Santa voice!
Nnmuhh
Nnnduhh
You bastard kiddies
*giggling uncontrollably* When I get out of this...
...Ball
*giggles*
Nnbuhh...
*More 'Santa' sounds*
*Giggling uncontrollably* That voice doesn't work!
It doesn't work in a whisper!
Little Johnny
You will not mock-
You'll-
Little Johnny
What have you done to become immune...
... To my swords?
Little Johnny, if you dodge this next one...
I will officially stop hating on you
Little Johnny...
... Have a nice day.
[Muted outro music: Crazy La Paint - MiniMusicMan]